you're doing i believe splinter cell for
netflix
oh yeah man right so if i'm not mistaken
you were given a two season pickup that
was 16 episodes
is that accurate kinda but i mean it is
it is kind of like the the two c the
first one is officially greenlit
you know and it'll be it'll be eight
episodes and uh
um the bible for that i'm i i'm
finishing up tomorrow and sending off
uh and that's just the that's the polish
of everything involved and
i have to ask you you're finishing a lot
of bibles between yesterday and today
what's been going on i think it's all
coming to a head right now it's just
honestly your timing on these things i
like i have all these post-it notes all
over the place and stuff to read
i think most of writing is emails
treatments
pitches phone calls emails when you
finally get the chance to write you're
like oh [ __ ] this is what i'm doing for
a living right
um but it's just you know your questions
are just everything's kind of coming to
the head
where like you look at falcon winter
soldier you spent so much time in the
room
breaking the story that by the time
malcolm releases you to write the script
you got about a week
you know and it's kind of joy and hard
and all that kind of stuff but you're
like all the heavy lifting's done
now you get to write and i would say the
bible in the format that's heavy lifting
once it's in like
off we go and animation is [ __ ] cool
you send in a script
and they make it like it isn't a matter
of casting this this this that
it's like what do you want to do derek i
think this would be cool that would be
cool we started
now it takes forever because it's
animation but still that kind of uh play
time is fun
right so with splinter cell you're
sending in the bible
the so you got picked up for eight
episodes but the plan is most likely to
do 16.
yeah with that because i just watched
invincible
and those episodes were like 45 50
minutes
uh are you envisioning for splinter cell
like 20 30 minute episodes like
what are they going to do i like i like
the idea of 20 30 minute episodes i like
the idea of
uh following two different you know
timelines being introduced to a
character
uh both when you know upon inception and
and where he is now and i think what you
can do is
it just leaves it leaves the audience
watching more where it's 12 40 at night
and you're like ugh i kind of want to
watch another one oh 24 minutes cool
you know um i just want to render it
down to simplicity you know and i know
i'm a writer i'm supposed to say
you should really read my dialogue but i
like the i like the unspoken
unspoken narrative and in animation uh
it's incredibly powerful when you can do
a sequence of events
and just have music you know and it's
all character moments and so splinter
cell uh has been enjoying that regard
yeah i'm just thinking about that gi joe
comic of uh
snake eyes it was all silent yeah oh
dude
yeah i remember that one right so i'm
just wondering is that something that
like for splinter cell where there could
be
you know um i'm just guessing here but
like you know you think about splinter
cellar i don't know if you're much
you're probably gamer but like remember
thief back in the day on the pc oh yeah
those are some of my favorite games is
it leaned into
uh the covert the stealth of it all and
yet when you got a kill it was
more satisfying than you know commando
with a bulletproof hedge
i would much rather do something where
uh you kind of
feel like oh he's about to get caught
and he realized no that's part of his
the the brinkmanship the the chess game
he's playing in these various things
and because of these guys and what
they've done in the past and seeing the
scissor reels
it really comes down to uh the light and
dark of it all
and it you know it's it's it's glorious
man
when is it going to be on the air what's
the plan is it like next year
probably two years probably not about 18
months you know these things from
inception to execution
are 18 months or two years um you know
my job will be done probably in six
months with with the other writers you
know
um and yet you are always on on on
standby to go like this isn't working
this line sucks the actor wants to do
something cool um but i also believe
that especially in animation if they can
have all the episodes in hand
uh going into it uh i make their job
easier too
you know oh completely but so the plan
is assuming you get to do 16 episodes
uh is it one of these things where
that's like a contained storyline for
those 16 episodes
if netflix said we want to do another
season like how would that work
no i like every season is going to be
self-contained outside of
the evolution of the main character you
know um
i like having one big bad one
overarching you know story
one background story with the aab of it
all and yet
i look at everything i do almost
everything especially in film and tv
as the best westerns he rides off from
the sunset because he's gonna do the
same [ __ ] thing in the next town over
you know
uh until you know he dies doing it and
with with these characters that we get
to have fun with
you want to see what their next step is
you know how i mean i remember back in
the day you see a
a sequel for something like uh really
and then you see it you're like
i think that's better than the last one
like they they took a little bit of a
u-turn
and i think that kind of stuff is fun
well the thing i
i think about splinter cell and
especially being animation
is that you can do some really cool
visuals with that material
and use a color and there's there's a
lot of
aesthetic choices that could really be
different
is that something you guys are planning
on and have they announced who's doing
the animation
um not yet i think that they'll do that
soon once everything's said and done
and you know my input is just like as a
fanboy in regards to seeing like they
came to me with the animatic going
hey this is what we kind of want to do
and i'm like that's cool let's play
um and so those announcements should be
coming out soon man